now when you get to the sentencing the
court has received read and consider the
probation report you know of any legal
cause where sentence should not be
pronounced none your honor this formal
arraignment waive it is does it fit in
which to make any statements probably
may I speak to him on their subject
I don't know the bailiff you won't
understand impossible
okay
don't ask me they probably chose it has
happened
and the grace high that I think
Americans giving every dollar she left
and beside the terrible arm accomplished
by
yeah
if I'm able to all contribute to society
office
translation
and I'm very sorry for
the time and I've wasted all these
people who worked very hard to
to
to convicting a pokémon and
and
I
at night the district attorney leads is
still on your dedication and your honor
as well thank you
and say think about his lawyers all
right Madison gets on all right the
victims live plea in the violating
section 187 the Penal Code to his murder
having been set pursuant to agreement
murder in the second degree is the
judging the sentence of the court the
benefit in prison the state prison terms
throughout by law to win 15 years to
life Stevie any actual friends since 9th
row six hundred ninety days actual time
he's there working pay $200 probation
two hundred are restitution fine at $200
parole revocation apiece at the estate
so to make restitution
twenty-five thousand seven or fifty two
dollars payable through probation you'll
be remanded to custody on the couch era
for delivery to the department
Corrections Portland Your Honor my
understanding is that mr. Reiser wishes
to replace mr. Tamar and I with another
lawyer
now that is limb sentence
he wishes to ask for 85% time of 15%
credit for time served mr. Reiser is
under statute when you are convicted of
a murder conviction there are no stage
credits given at the time of your
sentencing it's totally up to the parole
board is to win your release it's an
indeterminate sentence
you